sleep around the verge of a major
breakthrough over support of the people
then you'll prevail before this loan at
least people's tax bill actually went
slightly down Elon Musk often talk shop
on the small screen and increasingly
makes cameos on the big screen like this
one in Iron Man 2 musk also has screen
time the new Robert Rodriguez film
Shetty kills about a tough guy who's far
from tech-savvy ready for this good for
called Texas tweet what tipped it off
Rodriguez was toying with the idea of
sending his main character to space when
he ran into musk and I was at a
Hollywood party Nealon must walks in and
start talking about space he's going oh
we will go to Mars we're gonna call the
nice Mars sounded like the guy in my
movie so I went to visit his set up and
he showed me one of his Rockets called
the Falcon so why they call this Falcon
Oates after the Millennium Falcon of a
Star Wars fan oh my god this is like
writing I think writin itself
Musk told Bloomberg West Robert is a
friend of mine and it seemed like a fun
thing to do
he even lent Rodriguez footage of
rockets taking off to help build the
framework for a character played by Mel
Gibson Noah had his art I got mine as
for musk cameo it's at the end of the
movie is machete boards a spaceship and
after the scene was filmed he invited me
into outer space are you gonna will you
go no space for babies space for real